[Music]
my name is sophia bogle
i've been restoring books for over 25
years and i started my company savior
books
so that anyone can learn archival book
repair the book i'm restoring today
is the hans christian andersen fairy
tales book
from the late 1800s early 1900s
the first thing that we do in pretty
much any full restoration is we have to
separate
the cover from the text block the tool
that i prefer to use is the book repair
knife it has a rounded tip and
is less likely to do damage that you did
not intend
as an exacto knife would i'm removing
the old tape
it's very acidic and if i leave it on
the book at all it's going to affect the
book later on
when you're removing some of the
original material
and you know you're going to be
replacing it with something it's good to
mark
where it was in relationship to the
other materials
and so in this case i've used a pencil
and a piece of paper
to mark where the original went
i'm using a 100 grit sanding block
to clean the edges of these boards off
it makes a nice clean edge
[Music]
a lot of general cleaning can be done
using
a book repair knife i'm using the book
repair knife to just remove some
clumpy bits that are stuck to the end
paper
when you're repairing a book usually all
the pages are still connected and there
are some pages that
will benefit from this washing technique
that i have
it'll help us to get the tape off of the
page
in a way that you couldn't do if it was
attached to the book still
to wash a page to get rid of
the tape you just have to put it in
fairly hot water you aren't going to
need
any additives to clean these pages
it's just hot water it's surprisingly
effective
it can sit in the water for hours
you're also just going to have to be
very delicate with
the paper because it's in a more
delicate state when it's in the water
i'm using a micro spatula to help
separate the pages
and i'm also using a ruler to help hold
down the other page
[Music]
you can use a soft brush to help you to
brush away the old adhesive
[Music]
when you're touching up anything black
on a cover
you're going to want to use an archival
pen
it's a .08 micron pen and
it is archival ink the smaller the tip
the better in a way
do not use a sharpie those will damage
and discolor
[Music]
while i was cleaning i also noticed that
some of the guilt stamping has been
removed when i'm using the word
guilt guilt refers to gold so it's gold
stamping on the cover some people would
call it embossing
originally this was stamped with hot
metal
plates with foil coming down onto the
book
the best way to fill in
gilt stamping is to use shell gold
i'm using a liner brush and i have all
the control in the world
you're gonna make mistakes you can
actually remove
the guilt by using a cuticle stick
and then you can clean up your guilt
if you want to match the color of your
book
and do touch up on the covers it's not
as hard as you might think
you look at this this is a greenish
brown the
brownish colors that tend to be on these
older books
they they're muddy looking and the way
to get to that
muddy looking color is to go across
the color wheel from the color you think
it is
and add that other color to make it more
muddy looking
[Music]
when you find tears on your pages and
you want to repair them
i highly recommend using japanese tissue
that's thin and an archival paste such
as what i have here which is nori paste
it's a rice starch paste
a really thin tissue is going to be
better than a thicker tissue
you don't need very much paste
you get everything ready you've got your
book in the cover right side up
[Music]
you're going to be gluing all of those
materials you're going to glue
that mull and that little hinge and
you're gluing
that decorative end sheet back and then
you're going to
close the cover
[Music]
and then you slip a sheet of wax paper
in
and then you put the pressing board in
when i discovered that there were pages
missing from this book
i found a version of the story that
connected to where the book started
with the pages missing i used
paper that's called antique end leaf
i am using a colored pencil to color the
edges
of the new pages that i added to the
book
i don't want them to pop out i don't
want it to look obvious that i added
these new pages
[Music]
and that's it that's our book
[Music]
you